welcome back to CBS this morning we
reported on the Trump administration's
push to reopen schools during the corona
virus pandemic many health experts say
that's just too soon to bring your
children back to the classroom the
president points though to other
countries that he says have done it
safely this morning Holly Williams takes
a look at those schools and how they're
doing Holly the virus is having a
far-reaching effect on education in this
country good morning to you good morning
more than 1.5 billion students around
the world have had their education
impacted by the new corona virus
according to the United Nations and now
many parents around the world share the
same mixed feelings on the one hand they
don't want their children to miss out on
any more learning on the other hand
they're worried about the risks of
returning to the classroom in Israel
students went back to school in May when
the country had flattened the curve of
new infections but since then there's
been a spike in cases an outbreak in one
school in Jerusalem infected over a
hundred and fifty staff and students but
opinion is divided about how much
schools contributed to the surge in new
cases professor Arno Fontenay is an
epidemiologist and told us there's
evidence that the risks involved in
reopening schools depends on age primary
school age children are less contagious
to others compared to for instance
adolescents or adults President Trump
tweeted that Germany Denmark Norway and
Sweden reopened their schools with no
problems but most European countries
waited for their infection rates to drop
before sending children back to class
in Taiwan schools were only closed for
two weeks and though there are lots of
measures in place to prevent new
infections life is pretty much gone back
to normal but with tough measures from
its government Taiwan has had fewer than
500 confirmed infections and just seven
deaths so may not be comparable to the
u.s. in the UK with the highest death
toll in Europe a group of pediatricians
said keeping schools closed will
exacerbate inequality and risks scarring
the life chances of a generation of
young people
professor Fontana is himself a father of
four we were you worried when you sent
your children back to school they can
wear masks they can wash their hands
they can keep physical distance and it's
matter of self-discipline you know and
they have to learn but the professor
also acknowledged that maintaining that
discipline as he put it is much more
difficult for younger students Anthony
sure is Holly Holly Williams in Turkey
thanks